- Good afternoon, ladies and gentlemen,
and welcome to the 2021 Yale University,
Joint Military Commissioning Ceremony.
We are gathered here today
to continue a tradition
rooted in military history and custom.
Today, we celebrate
these young men and women
joining the ranks of
those in our armed forces,
who have commissioned before them.
We would like to thank all
of you gathered here today
for supporting these new officers.
And joining us for this
momentous occasion.
There are several moments in this ceremony
when it is appropriate to stand:
for the arrival of the official party,
the National Anthem,
the invocation,
and the departure of the official party.
We ask that you now silence
all electronic devices.
The ceremony will begin shortly.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please rise for the arrival
of the official party
and remain standing for the
National Anthem and invocation.
Colonel George. R. Grandholm.
United States Air Force commander,
Air Force ROTC detachment
nine, Yale University.
Captain Ronald. L. Withrow.
United States Navy,
commanding officer,
Naval ROTC, Yale University.
Today's honored guests
and keynote speaker.
President Salovey.
President of Yale University.
(audience clapping)
Scott A. Strobel.
Provost of Yale University.
(audience clapping)
Kimberly M. Goff-Crews.
Secretary and Vice
President for Student Life,
Yale University.
(audience clapping)
Marvin Chun, Dean of Yale College.
Sharon M. K. Kugler,
Yale University chaplain.
(audience clapping)
Oh,
say
can you see,
by the dawn's early light.
What so proudly we hailed,
at the twilight's
last
gleaming.
Whose broad stripes and bright stars,
through the perilous fight,
O'er the ramparts we watched,
were so gallantly streaming?
And the rocket's red glare,
the bombs bursting in air,
gave proof through the night,
that our flag was still there,
Oh,
say
does
that
star-spangled,
banner
yet wave,
O'er the land
of the free
and the home
of the
brave.
Chaplain Kugler will now
deliver the invocation.
- [Sharon Kugler] All
mighty, and gracious god.
It is you who are all powerful and loving.
It is you who calls us
to our full humanity.
Today, may we feel thoroughly
embraced by your presence.
As we accept a new and
daunting responsibility.
We understand this commissioning
as both blessing and burden.
Walk with us, as we seek to
be light in the darkness.
Striving to be generous,
merciful and just.
Enable us to act morally
and with boldness.
To defend and foster,
the equality of a person,
the hopes of a people,
the justice of the ages.
Merciful God, as we begin our
lives as leaders in this time
fraught with uncertainty.
Bestow upon us,
the spirit of wise judgment and courage.
The spirit of good counsel and strength.
The spirit of patient
knowledge and reverence.
Eternal God, may our greatest
triumphs always be discovered,
as we walk in your light.
As your beloved children
from many families of faith.
May we be ever inspired,
by the spirit of service,
we witness on this day,
and all days, for this we say,
amen.
- Please be seated.
At this time,
I'd like to welcome,
Captain Withrow,
commanding officer
of Naval ROTC at Yale University.
(audience clapping)
- Good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you, chaplain Kugler,
for your kind and thought
provoking invocation.
You certainly set the stage,
for what is sure to be a dignified event.
And wow, it certainly is
a beautiful day outside.
Isn't it?
It's great that there's a
little bit of a breeze here.
Welcome everyone, both in person
and in simulcasts land out there.
A special welcome to president Salovey,
Provost Strobel,
Dean Chun.
Secretary and Vice President Goff-Crews.
Thank you for allowing us to
host this in person event.
We really appreciate this.
Also, welcome to the deans
and the heads of college.
Also Dean Lavesque and Dean Sodi as well.
And also thank you, to those,
for your incredible support
to our ROTC programs,
over the course of the past
year, and the many years
previous.
I'd also like to ascend a welcome
to the members of the
Yale veterans association.
Thank you for all that you
have done for our midshipmen
and cadets as well.
To the staffs of the Naval and Air Force
ROTC, commissioning marks,
the culmination of years of your hard work
fulfilling our mission to train
and develop these midshipmen
and cadets, into military officers.
So well done.
(audience clapping)
I also wanted to say, welcome.
To retired rear Admiral Joe Callow
and his wife retired Captain
Sally Mackelreef Callow.
They're watching from
afar in New York city.
Admiral Callow is Yale
Naval ROTC class of 1958.
He's also a benefactor to Naval ROTC unit.
In fact, they're gracious endowment,
in small part was used to
purchase commissioning kits
for each of the midshipmen,
definitely alleviating some of the,
the financial burden of
initial uniform outlays.
So thank you, Admiral and Sally.
And saving the best for last.
A special welcome, to the
parents and loved ones
of our midshipmen and
cadets, who are watching
from afar,
maybe from across the Plaza
back there, I believe.
So another round of applause.
(audience clapping)
So, what do I say,
to an intrepid group of
incredibly talented and spirited
men and women about to
embark on their careers
in our nations Marine
Corps, Navy, Air Force
and Space Force.
Simply this.
You are ready, now get to work.
Now, this is not the end of my remarks.
So we've got a couple of pages to go here.
So of course, I'm going to expound a bit.
Your entire life,
you have been developing
your personal virtues
and leadership traits.
You have your parents,
coaches, teachers, ROTC staff,
religious leaders, amongst
others to thank for that.
But you should also enjoy
personal satisfaction.
Knowing your perseverance,
creativity, thirst
for knowledge, are also
significant factors
in you sitting here today.
It's taken a lot of hard
work to get to this point.
The starting point of
your military careers.
And it will take a lot more
hard work on your part.
And on the part of the
teams you will lead.
And midshipman,
I checked the latest revision
to U S Navy regulations,
Before I came here.
I didn't see any prohibition
against hard work.
So hard work is still authorized.
Hard work is authorized,
but so is smart work.
You're all well aware of this,
after having navigated the past year plus.
We live in an era of revision as powers
challenging our role
as a democratic leader,
and defender of freedom and
democracy around the world,
challenging us security
interests, and those
of our allies, and seeking
to consume weaker nations.
This requires our military
to be strong and smart.
You must be strong.
In 1630, John Winthrop, leading Puritan,
figure and first governor of the
Massachusetts bay colony,
spoke of Massachusetts
and his early settlers,
as a city on the hill.
A shining example to the world.
His Clarion calls, continued
to define our nation.
But ours is a tenuous position,
requiring the resolve and commitment
of our people, our elected officials,
and our nation's military,
when called upon,
to deter those who wish ill upon us,
our allies, and our shared interests.
And when necessary to confront them.
You midshipman have learned,
of the critical role
sea power, and maritime strategy plays
in the defense of our city on the hill,
our nation,
the ideals we hold dear,
and our allies.
You have been introduced
to the critical role
of joint teamwork,
with our fellow services,
such as the air force and space force.
And with our partner nations.
Sea power requires people power,
and strong leadership,
your leadership.
So today in about 30 minutes,
you'll recite the oath
of office, swearing loyalty
to our constitution,
and the country whose course it directs.
Then donning the cloth of our nation.
And with sea bag in hand,
you will embark on the
journey of a lifetime,
as a Naval officer.
I rest easy knowing you
are taking the helm,
because I know you are ready.
And because I know you
will continue to work hard,
and smartly.
To our midshipman.
And this is the last
time that I will refer
to you as midshipman.
I know I speak on behalf
of the staff of Naval ROTC,
when I say I'm incredibly
proud of your achievements,
and greatly look forward
to watching, from a shore,
as you cast off all
lines and get underway.
You are an extremely
talented and promising group
of leaders,
warriors,
with certainly a few budding
admirals and generals
in the mix I'm sure.
So,
Muhammad,
Valenti,
Kay, Bella, Sophia,
Charlie and Jacob.
You too Alegra.
In short order.
Welcome to the officer's
mess and the wardroom.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- At this time,
I'd like to welcome,
Colonel Grandholm.
Commander of Air force
ROTC at Yale university.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you, Cadet Rebelson.
So good afternoon, ladies and gentlemen.
Today, is indeed a special
day for our graduates.
Both for the journeys, that
they are about to take,
and for the obstacles,
they have overcome over
the past four years.
I think we can all agree,
that this year has been unlike any other,
in the history of ROTC at Yale.
It's been a year of immense challenges,
and personal loss, for many
of us here in the audience.
We have lost, friends and family members.
We have faced financial and
professional disruptions.
And we have struggled to
maintain personal connections,
via zoom,
while sequestered away from
each other, for over a year now.
Yet with all that we have faced,
I think, it is even more important,
for us to come together today,
and celebrate this momentous occasion.
As the members, of the ROTC Class of 21,
affirm, their willingness
to support and defend
our country as commissioned officers.
I'd like to first acknowledge
the incredible support,
that we receive from the Yale community.
Demonstrated,
by the presence of our
distinguished guests today.
President Salovey,
thank you for your personal engagement
on behalf of our cadets.
Provost Strobel,
Secretary Goff-Crews.
and Chaplain Kugler.
I greatly appreciate
your presence here today.
And your support of our ROTC program.
Dean Chun,
thank you for helping our students
through the many challenges
they have faced this year.
And for expediting
numerous, special requests
for essential military training.
Thank you to the deans
and heads of colleges,
who have joined us today,
for your patience in dealing
with arcane military paperwork,
and for the personal care and concern,
that you have shown for your students.
Thank you also, to Adrian,
Henry,
and Sean.
Representing the Yale
Veterans Association,
and the Yale Veterans Network.
For all the support you
have given our cadets.
Financial and otherwise.
I'd also like to recognize
our ROTC liaisons.
George Lavesque and Risa Sodi.
Who not only have been
forced to learn Air Force
and Navy lingo and acronyms.
But who also worked tirelessly
to advocate on our behalf,
with the larger Yale community.
Along with the air force and Navy cadre,
who made the ceremony possible today.
I'd like to especially highlight,
our two planning leads,
Cadet Anne Northrup and
Cadet Molly Rockelset.
I think we can all agree, that
they deserve the most credit
of anyone, in making
this ceremony possible.
Thank you for volunteering.
(audience clapping)
And, to all of you, joining
us via the live stream,
including the friends and families,
of our graduating cadets and midshipmen.
Welcome.
So to our Air Force ROTC Class of 2021.
You are about to take the
next step on a journey,
shared by men and women in uniform,
since the continental army,
was established in 1775.
An army, which included students,
who stood just steps away from here,
on their commencement day
two and a half centuries ago.
You have all heard me
say, probably a few times,
that ROTC is first and foremost,
a leadership program.
That, regardless of what
job you are going to do,
in the Air Force or Space Force,
you will all be leading,
our airmen and guardians,
in accomplishing your assigned mission.
Fortunately, for those
airmen and guardians,
we have an incredible group
of leaders in the class of 21.
Your leadership, is what
allowed our cadet wing,
to overcome the countless
challenges we face this year.
To create, an entirely new
hybrid training program,
at a few weeks notice.
And to do it all, with a positive attitude
and can-do spirit.
You have innovated,
you have raised the
intensity, when necessary,
and you have shown, our
first and second year cadets,
how to lead.
But what I am most grateful for,
is the care and concern,
you have demonstrated
for your fellow cadets.
You have internalized the
most important attribute,
you will need as a military leader.
Putting the needs of the
team, above your own.
Almost a 105 years ago,
12 Yale students, founded
the Yale Aero club.
Which later formed the nucleus
of the first deal unit.
When they took their
oaths, on March 24 1917,
at the Naval submarine base in New London.
They probably could not imagine,
that their service,
would bring them to the
battlefields of Belgium,
and France, in under a year.
I know that when I was
commissioned in 1998.
I would not have predicted, that a little
over three years later,
the United States would
embark on the longest war,
in our history.
A war, for which I, and most
of our cadre members here
today, have deployed multiple times,
as well as some of the veterans,
with the YVA and YVN.
For all of you about to join,
our nations officer corps today.
I do not know where
and how you will serve.
Or if your service, will
lead you into combat.
What I do know,
after spending the past year with you,
is that I am confident
you will serve with honor
and distinction.
And will lead our air
force and space force,
through whatever challenges
we face in the years to come.
I congratulate each of you,
and I thank you,
for the spirit of service, on
behalf of our great nation.
It is now my great pleasure to introduce,
Dr. Peter Salovey,
23rd president of Yale University,
and the Chris Argyris
Professor of Psychology.
It is entirely fitting
that President Salovey,
is our guest of honor today.
His groundbreaking work,
with John D. Mayer,
on emotional intelligence, is used widely,
across the department of defense.
And is now an integral part,
of how the air force
trains our future leaders.
Presidents Salovey, has
been a strong supporter
of the ROTC program at Yale.
And going back to his time,
as an intern, at the west
Haven, VA medical center.
He truly understands
issues, facing our veterans.
And active duty military members.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Thank you.
President Salovey.
(audience clapping)
- Good afternoon, everyone.
It's truly an honor, to be
here to congratulate the class
of 2021,
of the Yale reserve
officers training corps.
And thank you, Colonel
Granholm and Captain Withrow,
for inviting me to do so.
To all the families,
and friends, and loved ones,
watching via live stream.
You're very close to our hearts.
On behalf of my wife,
Marta,
and my colleagues across the university.
Thank you,
for all you have done,
to support these cadets,
our graduates.
And finally to the ROTC class of 2021.
Thank you, for your commitment to Yale.
To the United States.
To the common good.
We're proud of all you've
accomplished at this university.
But even more, we are
grateful for your service.
Soon, you will not only
graduate from Yale.
But also receive your commissions
into the United States,
armed forces.
You will affirm your allegiance,
to the constitution, of the
United States of America,
and pledge to defend, our democracy.
You take on this responsibility
at a critical moment,
in our nation's history.
The COVID-19 pandemic,
continues to claim lives,
around the world.
The geopolitical effects of
this crisis will be felt,
for years to come.
And we face other challenges.
Extremism,
sectarian violence,
environmental catastrophe,
poverty.
And yet, in spite of these
and other serious threats,
I'm encouraged by what I see.
Talented,
promising,
courageous men and women.
You've worked hard at Yale.
In your classes,
in your ROTC training.
You've made personal
sacrifices in the service,
of a larger goal,
to make our nation and our
world safer, and more secure.
You have done this, not,
just for yourselves,
in fact not for yourselves,
but for others.
Not only for the present,
but for future generations.
Although you have chosen a difficult path.
You do not go at it alone.
You join a great legacy
of military service
at this university.
You go in the footsteps of Nathan Hale,
Yale college class of 1773.
And revolutionary war hero.
And of Cortlandt van Rensselaer Creed.
The first African-American,
to earn his medical degree
from Yale.
Creed, graduated at 1857
and joined the union army,
as soon as he was permitted to enlist.
You go in the footsteps of
Rear Admiral Grace Hopper.
Who earned her PhD at Yale.
When she retired from the Navy,
at the age of 79.
Amazing Grace, was the
oldest serving officer,
in the U.S Armed Forces.
And you tread the path,
walked by many others, whose names are,
not familiar to us.
Nearly 30,000 Yale graduate served,
in the first and second world wars.
In Korea and Vietnam.
Others have fought in recent wars,
and serve around the globe today.
Your service honors those,
who have made the ultimate sacrifice,
in defense of this country.
The names of over a thousand Yale alumni,
killed in wars, since
the American revolution,
are carved into the
walls of Memorial hall,
right over their.
The freedoms, we hold dear.
The prosperity, we enjoy.
Were made possible.
By previous generations of
military, service, people.
I know your decision,
to accept a commission
in the United States armed
forces has not been made lightly.
You've already given up, many
comforts and conveniences,
and you will give up many
more, in the years ahead.
Thank you.
Thank you for showing us by your example,
what it looks like,
to make sacrifices, for the common good.
Today, as we recognize your achievements.
We also mark another important milestone.
10 years ago,
Yale College,
voted,
to restore the ROTC TL.
I'm very proud of this decision.
It is only right, that a university,
with such a rich history of service,
should welcome the ROTC on our campus.
And over the past decade,
we have worked with our military partners,
to prioritize the Yale ROTC program,
and expand support and
opportunities for veterans.
Each cadet contributes to this community.
You bring distinctive
perspectives and experiences,
to our campus.
You challenge and inspire,
your fellow students, faculty, and staff.
The ROTC presence brings
great honor to Yale.
But its importance, is much broader.
The partnership between
universities and the military,
serves the country's,
long-term strategic interests.
Both Yale and the U.S
military, prepare leaders,
for the great challenges ahead.
Yale will continue to advocate,
for funding,
and support for the ROTC.
As we educate students for
careers, in every sector,
including the military.
Today, I joined with so many others,
in applauding your
commitment, and your courage.
You leave here, taking what
you have learned at Yale.
And sharing it with a
world, in great need,
of light and truth.
Thank you all,
for what you have done.
for what you will do,
to fulfill Yale's mission,
to improve the world today,
and for future generations.
Congratulations,
Yale ROTC class
of 2021.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you, president Salovey.
We sincerely appreciate,
you being with us today.
Cadets, and Midshipman.
Please take your places on the stage.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we have now come to the
part of the ceremony,
for which these midshipmen and cadets,
have worked for, over the past four years.
The oath of office.
Would everyone please rise,
as the oath of office,
is administered to those
being commissioned,
as officers in the Marine Corps,
Navy,
Air force
and Space Force.
(oaths being taken)
(audience clapping)
- Second Lieutenants and Ensigns,
will pin on their new ranks,
in private ceremonies,
with friends and families.
Thank you all for
commemorating this occasion.
Please be seated.
Captain Withrow,
Colonel Granholm,
and President Salovey,
will now present the
commissioning certificates,
to the new ensigns and second lieutenants.
Adrian Boninburgher.
The president of the Yale
veterans association,
will present pin, to
each of the new officers.
Please hold your applause until the end.
Ensign, Jacob, Dean, Asher.
Ensign Asher, is from Coronado California,
and has graduated with
a degree, in economics,
from Yale university.
Ensign Asher, will serve
as a student Naval aviator,
at Naval Air station, Pensacola, Florida.
(audience clapping)
Ensign, Isabella, Marie, Bach.
Ensign Bach, is from Herndon Virginia,
and had graduated with degrees,
in English and Russian,
from Yale university.
Ensign Bach, will serve as
a submarine warfare officer,
at nuclear power training command,
in Charleston, South Carolina.
(audience clapping)
Ensign, Sophia, Ava, Bleak.
Ensign Bleak, is from
Birmingham Connecticut,
and has graduated with a degree,
in psychology from Yale university.
Ensign Bleak, will serve as
a surface warfare officer,
aboard the USS Dewey, home
ported in Yokosuka, Japan.
(audience clapping)
Ensign, Charles, Paul, Marker.
Ensign Marker, is from
Portsmouth Rhode Island,
and has graduated with degrees,
in mechanical engineering and
history from Yale university.
Ensign Marker, will serve
as a student Naval aviator,
at Naval air station, Pensacola, Florida.
(audience clapping)
Second Lieutenant, Valenti,
Hernandez, Bautista.
Secondly Lieutenant, Hernandez Bautista,
is from Houma Louisiana,
and has graduated with a degree,
in political science from Yale university.
Second Lieutenant Hernandez Bautista,
will attend the basic school,
at Marine Corps base, Quantico, Virginia.
(audience clapping)
Second Lieutenant, Kay, Lee.
Second Lieutenant Lee, is from
Westborough Massachusetts,
and has graduated with
degrees, in global affairs,
and applied mathematics,
from Yale university.
Second Lieutenant Lee, will
attend the basic school,
at Marine Corps base, Quantico, Virginia.
(audience clapping)
Second Lieutenant, Muhammad, Makhmudov.
Second Lieutenant Makhmudov,
is from Lilburn Georgia,
and has graduated with a degree,
in global affairs, from Yale University.
Second Lieutenant Makhmudov,
will attend the basic school,
at Marine Corps base, Quantico, Virginia.
(audience clapping)
Staff Sergeant, Alegra, Pankratz.
Staff Sergeant Pankratz,
is from Wichita Kansas,
and has graduated with a degree,
in global affairs, from Yale university.
Staff Sergeant Pankratz, will commission,
as a second Lieutenant, this summer,
and will tend the basic school,
at Marine Corps base, Quantico Virginia.
Staff Sergeant Pankratz,
has been designated,
the distinguished, midshipman graduate,
for Yale university and ROTC.
(audience clapping)
Second Lieutenant, Fiona, Eileen, Ashbury.
Lieutenant Ashbury, is
from Potomac Maryland,
and has graduated with degrees,
in east Asian studies, and
economics from Yale university.
Lieutenant Ashbury, will
serve as a gold bar recruiter,
at a location to be determined,
following which, she will
serve as a space intelligence
officer, at Goodfellow
Air force base, Texas.
Lieutenant Asbury, has been designated,
as an Air force ROTC
distinguished graduate,
a distinguish, distinction
earned by the top 10%
of cadets across the ROTC enterprise.
(audience clapping)
Second Lieutenant,
Joshua, Charles, Beasley.
Lieutenant Beasley, is
from Herndon Virginia,
and has graduated with a degree,
in computer science from Yale university.
Lieutenant Beasley will serve,
as a space acquisitions officer,
at Los Air force base, California.
(audience clapping)
Second Lieutenant,
Lauren, Ashley, Earhart.
Lieutenant Earhart, is from
Port Jefferson station,
New York,
and has graduated with a degree,
in criminal justice, from
the university of New Haven.
Lieutenant Earhart, will serve
as a security forces officer,
at Malmstrom Air force base, Montana.
Lieutenant Earhart, has been designated,
an air force ROTC distinguished graduate,
a distinction earned by
the top 10% of cadets,
across the ROTC enterprise.
(audience clapping)
Second Lieutenant, Patrick Harris Hurl.
Lieutenant Hurl is from
Plainville, Connecticut,
and has graduated, with
a Juris Doctor degree,
from Quinnipiac University School of Law.
Lieutenant Hurl, will serve
as a judge advocate general,
at Maxwell Air Force Base, Alabama.
(audience clapping)
Second Lieutenant,
Cheyenne, Holmes, Olmsted.
Lieutenant Olmsted, is
from Wolcott, Connecticut,
and has graduated with a degree,
in national security studies,
from the university of New Haven.
Lieutenant Olmsted, will serve
as an intelligence officer,
at Goodfellow Air Force Base, Texas.
(audience capping)
Second Lieutenant,
Tanner, John, Tabritski.
Lieutenant Tabritski,
is from Phoenix Arizona,
and has graduated with a degree,
in electrical engineering,
from Yale University.
Lieutenant Tabritski, will
serve, as a pilot trainee,
at a location to be determined.
(audience clapping)
Second Lieutenant, Tyler,
Alexander, Tabritski.
Lieutenant Tabritski,
is from Phoenix Arizona,
and has graduated with a degree,
in mechanical engineering and
physics from Yale university.
Lieutenant Tabritski, will
serve, as a Space force
developmental engineer,
at Los Angeles Air force base, California.
(audience clapping)
Second Lieutenant, Michael,
James, English, Waylon.
Lieutenant Waylon, is from
New York city, New York,
and Rome, Italy,
and had graduated with a degree,
in applied physics from Yale university.
Lieutenant Waylon, will serve
as a special tactics officer,
at Lackland Air force base, Texas.
(audience clapping)
Ensigns and lieutenants.
Please rise, to be recognized.
(audience clapping)
Ladies and gentlemen,
I present to you,
the newest second lieutenants and Ensigns,
of our United States, Armed Forces.
(audience cheering)
(audience clapping)
Ladies and gentlemen,
please remain standing,
for the playing, of the Marine Corps,
Navy,
Air force,
and Space force, service songs.
(Marine Corps service song)
(Navy service song)
(Air Force service song)
(Space Force service song)
- This concludes, the 2021,
joint military commissioning ceremony.
To our honored guests,
cadre, cadets, and veterans.
We wish you fair winds,
following seas,
and blue skies,
always.
(audience clapping)